[موسيقى]
بملامح عربيه ولسان فلسطيني وسلاح خفي
دسون في مناطق المواجهات بين الفلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال
انهم وحدات مستعربين او مستعربين كما تنطق
بالعبريه او فرق الموت كما يسميها
الفلسطينيون بدا ظهور وحدات المستعربين
منذ ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي وكانوا جزءا
من عصابات الهجنه
وافرادها خليط من شتى اجهزه الامن
والمخابرات الاسرائيليه كجهاز الامن العام
الشباك وجهاز الاستخبارات الموساد واحيانا
من الشرطه الاسرائيليه نفسها
ينطق افراد وحدات المستعربين بلون بشره
وملامح مشابهه للملامح العربيه ويخضعون
لتدريبات في معهد خاص هو قريه صناعيه
تشابه قريه فلسطينيه لتعلم تفاصيل الحياه
الفلسطينيه ودراسه تاريخ العرب
والفلسطينيين ولغتهم وعاداتهم
[موسيقى]
دول وحدات المستعربين مهام عده منهم من
يمارسوا مهام اعتياديه بالاندساس بين
الفلسطينيين لاعتقار شخص مطلوب او جمع
معلومات او تصفيه شخصيات من المقاومه
ومنهم من ينشطون داخل السجون الاسرائيليه
ويسمون العصافير وهؤلاء يدخلون السجون على
هيئه السجناء امنيين وتكون مهمتهم نسج
علاقات مع الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال للحصول
على معلومات مهمه منهم اما النوع الاكثر
اثاره فهم المستعربون الذين يذهبون للعيش
وسط العرب فيخالطونهم ليل نهار لسنوات
طويله حتى يكون عينا حيه للاحتلال من داخل
صفوف الشعب الفلسطيني
وتكاثرت وحدات المستعربين ومسمياتها كوحده
شمشون في محيط قطاع غزه ودوبدوفان بالضفه
الغربيه ويمام التابعه لحرس الحدود وتختلف
مهماتها لكن جميعها يخدم الاهداف التي
يحددها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي